let's go to um let's go to Ricky from
Charlotte Ricky you can unmute yourself
and then I'll be able to hear you and
then we'll we'll be able to talk and
it'll be great Ricky you are self-muted
but you can unmute and then you will be
all good
hey Dave can you hear me I can hear you
fine
okay awesome I wanted to ask you I'm
trying to
sort of digest the
um results from the election and get an
idea of a lot of the meanings of the
results and one of the things I was
thinking about was
the the Republicans underperformance
what does what do you think this means
about
um a lot of the rights uh efforts and
Investments going all in on uh cultural
Wars and uh and especially like a lot of
their
um uh a lot of the Investments they've
made in alternative media seem like
Outlets like the daily wire turning
points USA and
um and and then just you know a plethora
of different like online streamers and
people like Tim Poole and like all these
things are doing like the disaffected
liberal Dancing Yeah and things like
that and seeing that it it seems to me
like I'm just surprised that none of it
has really shown up electorally I mean
is is that surprising I don't think it's
surprising and here's why
um based on what we saw online
it wouldn't have been crazy to expect
Bernie Sanders to win the 2020
Democratic primary if you looked online
you would have thought Tulsi gabbard
certainly must have more than two
percent support and Bernie's probably
going to run away with this thing and of
course that wasn't the case because so
much of of what voters do
doesn't involve posting to Twitter and
Reddit or whatever the case so sometimes
we we like misunderstand the size of a
movement based on looking at social
media similarly
even though for example in the lead up
to 2022
much of what we heard from Trump and
Kerry Lake and others was about they
stole 2020 and I really won and all this
different stuff
um a lot of Republican voters are not
interested in that and and to some
degree they rejected it right they
rejected J.R Majewski and John Gibbs and
Kerry Lake and Tudor Dixon and so on and
so forth now I think the risk is
some people look at one election and
they take some huge overarching
um uh conclusion from it and we really
shouldn't do that each election gives us
a little bit of information about a
couple of things so like it's not that
the stop the steal stuff isn't real
within the Republican electorate it's
just not quite as popular as it might
seem from following Trump and so it
didn't go that well for republicans and
so the important thing I think for
Democrats to do is to try to get a
better grasp on what isn't working for
republicans and for example it was a
good strategy for Democrats to play up
the the big lie stuff in 2022 because
they correctly assessed a lot of
Republicans aren't going for it I don't
know that there has to be some Grand
takeaway but it's a lot of little
takeaways
yeah no I I definitely agree with uh a
lot of the little takeaways
um uh the themes you know in the in the
results but the I guess the thing that I
I'm just like really interested in is
it seems to me like on a national level
like the Republican politicians have
really like adopted a lot of online
rhetoric and language and you see like a
lot of proximity with what
um you know this this new movement of
like young right-wing conservatives you
know like Ben Shapiro on The Daily wire
and Charlie Kirk and all of them and you
know and they have these things like
they have CPAC in the uh Charlie group
like has the Charlie Kirk's group has
like multiple events and stuff per year
and I'm like is that is that just be
like is it just they're investing in all
that because they're trying to push back
against the fact that there's this
Rising young voters that are left-wing
and they're scared to some degree yeah I
think they see the demographics they
know that 18 to 29 year olds are voting
pretty left and and unfortunately they
are smart to do what they're doing they
are pouring money into trying to grab up
those young voters and so my concern is
even though 18 to 29 year olds and soon
to be 18 year olds are a huge
opportunity for the Democratic Party the
Democratic party doesn't seem as
committed to pouring the money into
Independent Media shows and events and
this type of thing the right is smart to
do it and the left needs to get on the
ball
yeah
um so you think it could eventually
start showing some electoral effects it
could it could
okay yeah
um well I I hope that uh they catch up
on this because you know I I I I mean I
am glad to see that they weren't able to
effectively make you know trains in the
kids is this number one issue I don't
think anybody really voted on that and
stuff but
um they're clearly like trying a lot
with this cultural they absolutely are
they absolutely are we got to be ready
Ricky thank you for the call thank you
David all right there is Ricky if you
have a friend or loved one who is
passionate about the environment here is
a perfect holiday gift our sponsor
established titles is a project that
lets you ceremonially purchase as little
as one square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift of reforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 off and your plot of land
will be right next to mine you can see
it on a map go to establishtitles.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman for an
extra 10 off on top of their Black
Friday deal the link is down below